holy crap everybody we got our first
game of Thrones teaser trailer so we got
to break it down obviously just implying
what's going to be happening with the
final battle a battle of firing eyes HBO
is referring to this as the Dragonstone
teaser because it's taking place inside
Dragonstone in the room of the map table
where they spent most of season seven
planning all their battles we're also
doing a new round of that george RR
martin book giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite moment from the teaser on
the video so if you're not sure about
the perspective that they're giving you
here the beginning of the teaser where
the wall of ice at the top of the table
comes spilling in is meant to be the
wall so the left side is the north part
of the table the right side of the table
that you then shift to later in the
teaser is the south side when you're
coming up from King's Landing with the
fire this is a reference to the night
king in his army of White Walkers
breaching the wall and slowly making
their way south r.i.p wildlings r.i.p
umbers at the last hearth in r.i.p
Karstarks because there on the night
King's way as he comes down to
Winterfell
then when the wave of winter washes over
the wolf that's them crossing the
boundary of Winterfell so obviously big
battle happening at Winterfell they
spent a lot of time filming there it's
probably gonna be one of the biggest
spectacles of the season then when the
camera shifts right a little bit and you
see the cold go down this way this is
actually the Eyrie that we're looking at
in the Vale so that's just teasing that
the nice king's army is going to come
very far south obviously the fire
eventually meets it we'll talk about
where the fire meets it because that
kind of lets you know where the big
final battle is gonna take place you see
the twins you see Riverrun you see pike
all the big locations that we've been on
the show before represented on the map
as winter washes over them then winter
washes over the dragon that's meant to
represent Viserion because you see the
icicles hanging down from it so night
king gains the ice dragon then his
winter starts to spill over the Trident
and down past Harrenhal you see the
camera shift right and you see fire
coming up from the south and King's
Landing the fact that it's engulfing the
lion is meant to represent Cersei at
King's Landing even though it was a big
controversy during season 7 when they
did the intro they didn't change the
house sigil of the stag for Baratheon to
the Lannister lion when Cersei took the
throne which we all felt like they
should have because
essentially all living Baratheon's have
been eliminated with the exception of
Gendry but for the purposes of the show
the Lannisters had usurped the throne so
it should have been a lion on top there
so a lot of people felt like that was an
omission like they didn't want to spend
the time to go in and change that in the
opening credits even though they do
subtly change the opening credits every
season just a little bit maybe they'll
correct that oversight for the final
season we'll see but the fact that fire
is washing over the lion implies the
Daenerys dragons in her army with Jon
Snow and his army are going to overtake
King's Landing that'll be one of the
other big final battles there's two
essential huge battles that they'll be
fighting one of it Winterfell with the
night Kings army and then one down at
King's Landing we don't know exactly
who's going to be involved in that
battle but the thing is is that the fire
washes past the lion meaning that they
move north from King's Landing it is the
fire rises to meet the ice it almost
looks like they're meeting each other
near the Isle of faces up closer to the
twins like at this really small area
where the children of the forest had
previously tried to crack Westeros in
half because as the fire meets the ice
you see all this black rock rise up
that's meant to represent the final
battle in the role that obsidian plays
in defeating White's White Walkers and
the knight King although the actual
method of killing the knight King is a
little unclear like we don't know that
he's just as vulnerable to dragonglass
as the regular White Walkers are like
it's implied that he has a level of
power that goes way beyond them so it
might take something a little extra
special to kill him there been a lot of
theories about Aria's dad that it may
have belonged to Rhaegar Targaryen the
role that the Ruby plays in it they
spend a lot of time referring to it as a
touchstone in a beginning for the war of
the five kings even though there were a
lot of reasons for the war of the five
kings so the fact that it is now in the
hands of Arya a faceless person who's
supposed to be one of the most badass
killers on the show is no coincidence
but the fact that the fire is meeting
the ice just north of King's Landing
implies that the final battle will be
somewhere around there but this is meant
to be a very general teaser they just
plan a lot of metaphors so I wouldn't
take it too literally but they're
basically telling you how the season is
gonna go down where the big battles will
take place Winterfell with the wolf here
Don of King's Landing with the lion and
then a little bit north of King's
Landing with the night Kings army but
because we know that there's going to be
a big battle it
enter fell in episode three that also
implies that the night king will not be
defeated that won't be the final battle
with the White Walkers they'll actually
make it further south after that battle
so let me know in the comments what do
you guys think happens during that first
big battle because they did say that
they spent so much time filming it from
so many different perspectives so you
get a narrative thread for each
character through the battle instead of
just a couple quick scenes of them
killing a white or a white Walker and
then moving on to the next person
because you have drogon and Ragle
fighting the night King on vissarion's
back in a dragon battle is probably
going to be the highlight of that
episode even though there's so much
other stuff going on then recently there
were also the confirmations about some
of the character turns at the end of
last season that they have to pay off
this season too so given the fact that
there's gonna be a huge battle at King's
Landing and now we know it's confirmed
from the scripts and from Peter Dinklage
himself the tyrion is smitten with
Daenerys and is not happy about her
relationship with Jon Snow like what am
I gonna do with this cuz just as
everything was coming together
everyone's gonna join together to fight
inevitably game Australian's will tear
us apart it's dangerous for everybody
involved I'm sure it's good for both of
them in the moment but you don't even
get the relief of how beautiful it could
be or should be it's no it's just it's
not good but it should be but it's not
it's Game of Thrones it's a long history
of romance not ending well on this show
add to that that he's also still loyal
to his family even though nobody really
likes Cersei that much he still feels
like she's family and isn't gonna want
to kill everyone in King's Landing and
think about what would happen if the
nearest tasked him with taking the city
and what happened with Robert's
rebellion during the Mad King would
Jamie's twist there was a huge betrayal
so just on a character level I wouldn't
be surprised that they tried to find a
way to bring it back around to that like
give Tyrion a version of what Jaime had
to go through during the end of Robert's
rebellion there's been a lot of talk of
betrayals but I think the only things
that would cause Tyrion to betray
Daenerys would be asking him to kill a
lot of innocent people like the people
of King's Landing or to kill his family
I think even if it were Cersei if I give
him great pause and Daenerys knows that
but she's also kind of
given him that steer earlier during
season seven don't cross me or that'll
be the end of use he said the same thing
to varus as well but even though tyrion
and varys have their own little circle
apart from Daenerys where they talk
about her and all the problems they have
with trying to manage her I think that
Varys is a little more responsible to
the people like he cares about the realm
itself so he'll do what's best and he
doesn't care too much about collateral
damage in the way that tyrion might so
here's my other big question for you
guys let me know in the comments what do
you think the other big betrayals of
season 8 are going to be because the
cast tease that everyone is going to
betray everyone else I think they were
exaggerating a little bit like the drama
won't be that crazy but I do think that
there was a little truth in there like
there will be a couple of characters
that you care about main characters
betraying other main characters the
reason why they dropped this trailers is
because CC XP Brazil Comic Con is
happening this weekend and HBO did a big
game of Thrones panel because Comic Con
isn't happening till after season 8
premiere so this is like the last big
convention for them to come and answer a
bunch of questions and drop footage so
if there's any other cool information
that they drop or any details about
season 8 I believe a breakdown video
about it but like the title card for the
premiere says with the date it just says
April 2019
I've already done a breakdown video of
all the information HBO has given us in
the clues that kind of narrow that down
to a more specific date so just to make
a more conservative estimate I would say
tentatively pencil in April 28th which
is the last weekend in April for the
actual episode 1 premiere because there
are a couple of shows that they have to
air and unless they double up on
episodes they won't be ready to drop
Game of Thrones till the very last
weekend in April but they could always
change that schedule a little bit so as
we get new information and we get more
big trailers in January I'll do more
update videos about that so no worries
there's still a lot more new stuff to
come leave all your Game of Thrones
video requests in the comments below
congratulations Ernesto Reyes you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Game of
Thrones video please email me on the
about page my channel so I can get your
details click here to watch Kit
Harington talk about the end of Game of
Thrones and click here for all my new
fire and blood book Easter eggs thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome see you
tonight